in the transcriptomics to course we
focused on the linkages between gene
expression and phenotype we spoke about
key concepts that are needed to
understand the methods often utilized to
find differences in gene expression
between experimental conditions then we
discuss differential gene expression and
continue to look at typical challenges
of this approach we use the t-test and
then use D SEC 2 to run a differential
expression pipeline next we use factor
regression analysis and as a result we
learn to detect obvious differences
between preset groups as well as expand
on that idea to more subtle differences
represented by factors that might be
interacting with each other in this
video you will review what we learned in
the transcriptomics 2 course
transcriptomics 2 has four parts
introduction of transfer tommix 2 which
is a review of course objectives and
topics hypothesis testing concepts
related to the analysis of the
difference between means of sample
groups differential expression analysis
which are advanced methods for
normalization analysis and
interpretation of differentially
expressed genes and then factor
regression analysis which is an
understanding of regression and
application to factors that are
affecting experimental design our fifth
topics are reviewed a conclusion section
offers more technical details on each
method as well as a summary for the
course let's take a look at the course
material in greater detail the course
started with an overview of learning
objectives and identified the next
challenges after we generate our table
of expression we learn which genes we
should consider significant for
interpretation depending on the
experiments design we have several
considerations to make around our
strategies for analysis these include
analysis methods to select for
differentially expressed genes or for
genes that explain a given factor in the
experiment to address these questions we
reviewed the data in the gene expression
table depending on the type of steps
that we have selected in the RNA seek
processing pipeline we get an output
with the column names of samples and
genes in the rows as well as expression
levels in rpkm fpkm
TPM
or read counts this data has certain
properties that required additional
steps before they can be used in the
parametric test that we've discussed in
the course the methods included analysis
of the differences between means as well
as the analysis of variance both assumed
normal distribution that can be achieved
by log normal transformation further
normalization that affects a separation
of noisy and significant genes
representing the data was accomplished
by using quantile normalization the
table output from the processing
pipeline had to be prepared for analysis
which uses statistical terminology that
is prevalent in the course such as
p-values distribution mean and others we
also reviewed the idea behind the t-test
as an approach to identify genes with
differences in expression between means
of sample groups these concepts were
illustrated using a hands-on assignment
the assignment was designed to
illustrate how the statistical test
helped in selecting jeans with
detectable differences between the
triple negative and here are positive
subtypes of breast cancer that are
studied in the patient-derived xenograft
model project t-test is one of the
approaches used for hypothesis testing
which provides us with a p-value that
can be used to find genes with a true
non-random difference in the expression
levels between groups of samples however
multiple considerations for differential
gene expression analysis had to be made
along the way and included lognormal
transformation adjustment for false
discovery rate a calculation of the full
change and the annotation of found genes
to automate this process we were led on
packages such as D SEC and edge our
special attention was given to the
biological interpretation of bound genes
using annotation by gene ontology terms
as well as the grouping of genes
belonging to the same pathway to
understand the biology we focused on the
PD X models used in the project CID nog
mice have severe combined
immunodeficiency with no maturity and
b-cells SIDS CD 17 mice have severe
combined immunodeficiency but they have
normal natural killer cells macrophages
as well as granulocytes a thymic nude
mice lack of thymus and are unable to
produce t-cells
xid - lack of thymus resulting in no
functional t-cells and also have mutated
B lymphocytes we also looked at the type
of tumors in Arcata triple negative
breast cancer refers to any breast
cancer that does not express the genes
for estrogen receptor progesterone
receptor or human epidermal growth
factor - we then discuss the physiology
of the estrogen receptor and highlighted
a few key points the actions of estrogen
are mediated by the estrogen receptor
which is a dynamic nuclear protein that
binds the DNA and controls gene
expression we briefly discussed the flux
of metabolites from cholesterol to two
key intermediates ass trial and a strum
as well as how these intermediates
function to traverse their target cells
plasma membrane via simple diffusion
onto the nucleus where they bind to the
antigen receptor like other steroid
hormones estrogen enters passively into
the cell where it binds to and then
activates the estrogen receptor this
estrogen ER complex binds to specific
DNA sequences called hormone response
elements which activate the
transcription of target genes because
estrogen enters all cells its actions
are depending on the presence of the
estrogen receptor in the sewol the
estrogen receptors expressed in specific
tissues including ovary uterus and
breast for biological interpretation of
the differentially expressed genes we
found some intriguing insights into the
underlying differences between your
positive and triple negative breast
cancer of the 20 types of genes that
were upregulated in TN we saw the 4
belong to a class of molecules called
non-coding rnas specifically these were
long non-coding RNAs we also found the
two key factors in the neutrophil
migration pathway were differentially
expressed in TN breast cancer
these were TNF alpha ip6 and CXC l8 we
learned about how you sp30 a s once d ub
activity is down regulated in TN breast
cancer which inhibits the cancer cells
ability to modulate proteasome allegra
Bayesian ubiquitination is an
atp-dependent process that is carried
out by three classes of enzymes lastly
we just
sox9 overexpression and TN breast cancer
promoted beta-catenin nuclear
translocation key events that in concert
enhance the W and T pathway that acts to
modulate the nuclear transcription of
the genes in the TCF lef conduit in
summary this course was dedicated to the
downstream analysis which is a term
often used to represent the reductionist
approach to analysis collected data and
sequencing reads was reduced to a
stretcher table with thousands of
elements then we used analysis to find
an interpreted small number of genes
which were further grouped by their
common functions and interpreted by
pathway activity after a quiz we
proceeded to the second part of the
course that speaks about regression
which is a way to find relationships in
data this was illustrated using several
examples data that was intuitive such as
the association between body weight and
height as well as more complex and
biologically relevant such as insulins
role in up regulating the synthesis of
proteins and anabolic pathways the
t-test regression and factor analysis
models of powerful methods that deal
with data and they are embedded in
popular bioinformatics techniques such
as PCR edge are deseg network analysis
and anova these are commonly referred to
in publications with the assumption that
everyone understands their outputs which
are adjusted p-values r-squared
coefficients as well as the
relationships between the genes whether
they are statistics such as correlation
a biologic like a pathway interaction
after completing the course you should
be ready for more advanced analysis of
gene expression data in transcriptomics
3 we explore different methods for
identifying groups of samples without
prior knowledge and then examine methods
for developing classifiers from known
samples to classify unknown samples we
will then be enquiring the clustering as
well as the classification methods using
biological examples from the publication
by Damon at all which was modeling
precision treatment of breast cancer we
will reanalyze the data from the paper
and consider the differences between our
own analysis and those of the authors